hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Derrick Khanna
he is a yale law visiting fellow at the
information society project he's
formerly at the Republican Study
Committee we're gonna talk about why
that's formerly and a little bit Derrick
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me on you are a law school student
you're a fellow at a Yale Law program
you've recently wrote a couple of
articles about unlocking cell phones and
how that's now totally against the law
explain what unlocking a phone is and
what rule that's following you know that
runs afoul I'm sure so unlocking your
phone is when you allow for your phone
to use the SIM card of another provider
so this is like you you change the phone
or you you hack the phone a little bit
so it can go from being a t-mobile phone
to a verizon phone easier than that you
take your phone you plug it into your
computer you push a few buttons on an
unlocking program and now you can use
your phone on t-mobile or Verizon or
whomever you choose and now this is
illegal
yes presumably so okay and how do we
know it's illegal the content on your
phone is a protected mechanism that's
under the DMCA Digital Millennium
Copyright Act of 1998 that oversaw
various kinds of intellectual property
claims copyrighted yeah it was not it
was designed to protect copyright right
and so any attempts to get around those
protection regimes are considered to be
in a violation of 1201 of the DMCA and
so your phone has this material on it
and so trying to get around it through
unlocking is presumably illegal the
librarian of Congress was authorizing a
exception every three years so by them
choosing to remove the exception now
it's widely presumed and courts have
held in other cases in similar
situations that this would be covered on
the DMCA thereby triggering the criminal
statutes and what what kind of penalties
are we looking at both on the books and
then do people actually get charged with
shellacking their phones so you could be
looking at up to five years in prison
and half a million dollar fine in a
different in addition to the civil
penalties which are a little bit
different and so far no one has come
under these criminal penalties as far as
after the
can lapsed but people have been
threatened with these in the past so
motorola has sent out letters to people
saying you could be liable for up to
five years in jail cut it out
why did the librarian of Congress remove
the exception or not renewed the
exception again well the explanation
given was basically that they were
already products on the market that
allowed for you to buy it on lock phone
at seven hundred dollars or so a much
higher price point because you pay if
you want a phone that is compatible with
any system out of the box it cost more
money
well they'll choose yeah that's right
right yeah I mean the price is that much
right yeah you wrote a piece for the
Atlantic about this which you know just
went ballistic on reddit the social
media sharing site why do people care so
much about this why is this an outrage
because it's a basic question of
property rights who owns your phone at
the end of the day and if if this is
allowed to stand then the answer is that
you don't own your phone so this is
something that was asked for by one or
two wireless companies but t-mobile up
until the decision was asking their
customers to unlock their phones and
come over to them right so it's a real
problem for the free market and
unfortunately American consumers have
slower wireless speeds in most other
advanced countries we want more
competition this dynamic market and this
is a decision that's going to lead to
less competition higher threshold so I
mean this is a classic case of crony
capitalism really where a couple of you
know major corporations for the most
part are able to go to Congress or or
Congress's agents and say hey you know
what we don't like the provision of this
law would you change it in our favor
I feel like it's even more nefarious
than that which is that in 1998 a poorly
written statue the DMCA was passed and
it prohibited a wide swath of commonly
used technology in the name of defending
copyright I support copyright yeah and
let's talk about copyright in a second
but to go back to the DMCA explain how
the DMCA is the reason why we all rip
CDs but we do not rip DVDs
sure so the technology on your DVD that
protection scheme if you try to rip the
DVD if you try to basically encode that
DVD
and put on your computer that's a
violation of the DMCA and in fact even
discussing how it would be possible to
unlock your new DVD these are the
techniques that you would use these are
the codes could lead to your website
being shut down this isn't hypothetical
right websites have been shut down
because they taught people how to unlock
but and and those this is because DVDs
are covered under the DMCA in a way that
CDs are not that's correct
right so CDs just for historical
accidents really they're like old
records where you can tape make copies
of those on tape legally for personal
use DVDs even talking about
circumventing copyright encryption or
protection that's a federal offense yes
so let's talk about copyright because
you said you know you're in favor of
copyright you wrote last fall you
authored a memo for the Republican Study
Committee about why copyright was
problematic it was three myths about
copyright law and how to fix this or how
to address it run through the main
argument of your memo which then became
quite controversial and we'll talk about
that in a sec sure well you know I'm a
strong supporter of intellectual
property and the strong support of
copyright but the Constitution actually
says that Congress has an obligation in
this arena
it's one of their delegated powers but
unlike the other delegated powers it
actually says why it's a delegated power
yeah next appointment it says it's for
the purposes of advancing the sciences
in the arms the way you know among the
myths that you discuss in your paper is
that copyright actually is there to
compensate creators for instance that
copyright represents the free market at
work and that the current regime
actually leads to greater innovation in
productivity
none of that happens to be true right
yep yeah so talk a little bit about that
copyright when the Constitution was
written you if you were an author or
creator you got 14 years if you were
still alive at the end of that you could
renew it once for 14 years yes where are
we now in terms of copyright laws well
was even a little bit different than
that it was 14 years if you chose to opt
in he said I affirmatively want to use
this copyright protection and most
authors chose not to use it you know so
the default was that you didn't have
copyright and it was only for a few
limited forms of media today any form of
media is automatically copy
and it is copyrighted for life Plus 70
years and that means if I was for
individual authors and then for
corporate authors it's what about 90 95
years from publication and when you say
everything is copyrighted when I send an
email that email copyright write you a
note on a napkin to your friend okay and
this is distinct in part because in the
past you used to have to apply to the
Copyright Office and say hey I want this
to be copyrighted yes now it's just on
automatic absolutely so what are the
problems with copyright well there are a
lot of problems with the system that
we've transitioned to so our founding
fathers wanted a period where the
copyright would eventually expire so
most profit is derived in the first ten
years and then it really is declining
after that so what happens is is the
content producers after those ten years
most of their work is in red ever again
but what we see is when work eventually
enters the public domain when it's
available for free then viewership and
readership actually goes up so the
content producer all of a sudden has
their work to a whole new audience so
the founding fathers were aware of this
and they liked the idea that eventually
all work would go in the public domain
and everyone would be able to learn from
each other's work and they'd be able to
buy you know build derivative works off
of others and this is also I mean this
in here's in that the rationale in the
Constitution for copyright it isn't
specifically so Walt Disney can get rich
it's rather so that society has more
stuff to deal with exactly yeah and we
had a system that was analogous to that
for you know century well for over a
century and they started to extend it
slightly but they had reasons to extend
it you could argue today with the market
conditions that we have perhaps fourteen
years isn't the appropriate term but
today where we have it life plus a life
Plus 70 years yeah and what happened was
is every time that copyright was about
to expire for some of these profitable
works lobbyists would come to Capitol
Hill and they say hey we really need it
to be life plus twenty years and then
thirty years they'd come back and then
they'd say we need it to be life plus
fifty years and then then they said it
needs to be life Plus 70 years so it's
very clear what their intentions are
well and now the Republican Study
Committee is
no it is a group of self self-identified
self-described conservatives who want
the government to be limited they want
it to be within the constraints of the
Constitution your memo was up for a
little while and then it got pulled why
was it considered so hot an issue that
conservatives I mean you're not talking
about gay sex you're not talking about
immigrants you're not talking about
cutting defense spending you're talking
about copyright why was this too hot to
handle
and I'm sorry I can't I don't know you
don't know but yeah and you were never
told why okay we got to pull this down I
wasn't given a real reason on why it was
pulled on okay are you not given a real
reason or you're not at liberty to
discuss and I realize you are a law
student so you know you can put your
best face forward well I can I can tell
you that the memo was you know not that
out of the ordinary okay
my job was to pay was it vetted properly
did it go through the various
authorization challenge okay because
there was some talk that oh this one got
out Nana was published by mistake my job
was to push the box and bring in
conservative ideas that perhaps hadn't
been considered but were well versed by
the conservative community these were
ideas that in percolating occurs of
Concerned community for a long time and
this memo was approved through all the
normal channels and it actually went
through additional mechanisms and checks
and balances and provisions
is it simply a political position for
Republicans possibly to say you know
what we need copyright reform which
actually allies you with a bunch of
hackers and activists that tend to be on
the left in the computer world is this
mostly political posturing or is there
something is there a deeper commitment
to constitutional legislation well I can
tell you why I wrote the memo it was
constitutional fidelity is this really
black and white what the founders wanted
and it's black and white the system that
we have today and as far as consumer
principles go I think that we've really
stifled innovation here and we've
depressed the amount of content
available to the public what what are
the reforms you would like to see so
there's a large amount of works that are
called orphan works which is where you
can't identify who the content producer
is and that's a result of copyright term
of life Plus 70 years we have the
trackback who these authors
and particularly in corporate owned
ownership you know movie companies movie
studios go out of business record
companies go out of business or they go
into mergers and stuff just gets yes so
everyone loses as a result the you know
you imagine the original author probably
wants their self to be read or
disseminated their families aren't
making any money and the consumer can't
listen to the product to read the books
so there are lots of solutions that you
could imagine where Congress could fix
this problem and the content industry
which says they represent the artist
should also agree with that and then
there are some more more than that and
I'm sorry that might be that we just
create a sense of if somebody doesn't
claim the copyright to something then it
goes into after a certain period of time
it goes into the public domain that's
one solution another solution is to
allow for automatic licensing and have a
reserve fund for those artists and if
their families come forward then there's
this reserve fund and you use some of
those funds to try to investigate who
the artists are behind that music
there's a lot of solutions on the table
but allowing for all that content to be
unavailable is not a solution and now
it's I believe it's 2018 when the
copyright on Mickey Mouse arguably the
most you know lucrative copyrighted
material around and comes up what what
do you expect is going to happen in 2018
what kind of legislative battle will
there be about that oh I'm sure they're
gonna be vested interest who are going
to try to extend once again copyright
perhaps life plus 90 years but it's kind
of theater of the absurd I mean anyone
who who knows what their who actually
has read the Constitution will realize
this isn't the the limited times there's
that our founding fathers were talking
about and in fact our founding fathers
rejected the idea of an indefinite
copyright so this is something that's
very alien from our foundation and and
because they recognize that intellectual
property is not the same as real
property that it is a government grant
of monopoly yes and so it needs to be
for a limited period of time and that's
what the British courts held there was a
challenge this in the British courts the
House of Lords decided this is not a
natural right this is something created
by government that's beneficial but
created by government that's what the
United States Supreme Court decided and
that's where
fathers decide when they put this in the
Constitution and not just our founding
fathers in Washington DC but actually
across the country each state had their
own copyright law and their corporate
laws reflected that so both at the state
level and at the federal level our
founding fathers were well versed in
this and they all chose to reject the
argument of natural rights where is
reform going to come from on this
because I mean you you try to express
this through a conservative Republican
group Democrats in general are not
interested in this people like Al
Franken and other liberal democratic
senators are very much in the corner of
big entertainment companies and of
extending copyright and expanding it
where will reform come from I don't
think it's a left or a right issue I
think that there are pragmatic members
who want to find the answer and when
you're telling people that they can't
unlock their phones or when you're
telling people you're more egregiously
that blind individuals can't access
adaptive technology to read Kindle books
unless they get an exception from the
library in Congress this is this is
crazy I challenge any member of Congress
to be against a bill that gives adaptive
technology for the blind to read and and
so these are some positive ways to move
forward and I'll give you one more that
I also think is just as important to me
one of the most important parts of the
First Amendment is protecting political
speech and perhaps the second worst
violation of that is not by the
government but by individuals through a
hecklers veto
unfortunately the DMCA has authorized a
hecklers veto of political speech I
talked about that briefly you know how
can they get away with limiting
specifically political speech that's
what's in the first time absolutely so
this is what I find so problematic is in
2008 John McCain had a number of
campaign videos up on YouTube and an
individual file to take down requests
with Google and said we'd like you to
take down this content and it infringes
upon our copyright and so Google abided
and took down the campaign videos for
two weeks and then the thrust of the
election cycle and in 2012 was the
nature of the infringing material no
there was no infringement or it was it
was a fraudulent claim and in 2012 with
Mitt Romney's campaign the same thing
happened
and perhaps the most egregious example
of this was in the lead up last year to
the SOPA discussions Mike massive stop
online yes we are Mike Masnick with
Tector did an analysis on SOPA and why
he thought it was a terrible law the
exact thing that the first amendments
designed to protect but yet Google was
given a takedown requests and mastic
found out one day what he searched his
own article that it was no longer in the
top results and he contacted Google and
Google said oh we took it down because
if it take down requests and this is
Google which is known to be perhaps one
of the better operators in this field
but you've created a world where one
individual or a handful of individuals
who don't like content or speech you can
take down that content or speech for
potentially political reasons and
obviously again I support copyright when
you have you know pirated material that
needs to go but enabling the system that
allows for hecklers veto is not the
solution is is it that under DMCA when
you get a takedown order do you have to
comply in good faith or does Google are
they supposed to investigate you have a
very strong incentive to take it down
and then investigate and find out after
the fact so this really is like the
hecklers veto or you're shouting down
whereas at least for a short period of
time and again Michael these are easy
solutions which is again let's we
obviously the piracy issues is a serious
problem but let's deal with this one
particular issue let's say if you file a
false fraudulent takedown request with
absolutely no evidence behind it it's
clearly for political machinations that
you will be fined half a million dollars
or at least you will be stuck using
t-mobile or your carrier for the rest of
your life yeah it would stop it in its
tracks and and and if we're serious
about this you know why would content
supporters be against that you're
actually strengthening the best part of
the DMCA for their perspective well
we're gonna leave it there Derek where's
the best place for people to read your
work absolutely I'm publishing quite
widely the Atlantic and the National
Review are hosting some of my content
okay well thank you very much we've been
talking with Derek Khanna he's formerly
of the Republican Study Committee he
writes widely about the intersection of
public policy and information technology
for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie